fear is projecting what you believe to
be the outcome in front of you and then
feeling the energy right now and so with
that I like to invite you to project the
possibility that it can come true it may
take longer it may cost more but that it
can come true as well as looking forward
to realistic things as well I don't
expect to go from ten thousand dollars
to 10 million but I can require that I
go from 10 000 to 25. I set all my goals
that way I still have the site of a
million or ten or whatever that is
touching those many people but I give
myself incremental bites so that I can
get it done now when you talk about
validating your fears or dismantling
your fears what needs to take place
application what needs to take place in
order for you to stay in action look at
what strategy needs to take place here's
what I love I love that there's a
projection and then there's an actual
there's always that you think you know
what's going to happen when you're going
to the movies you think how a movie's
gonna turn out you think wow it's gonna
be when you go out to dinner you have an
idea what it's going to be like at an
amusement park and then all of those
projections are replaced with actuals
once you do it you go oh here's how it
was it was better than I thought it was
amazing no it was not all that whatever
you've replaced the projection with the
actual so here's the other thing when
you're managing fears and when you're
climbing over fears you want to look for
Action so you can replace the projection
with the actual because if you don't
replace the projection with the actuals
you're always sitting back going okay
what could have happened but you never
really know need motivation watch a top
10 with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Lisa Nichols and my take on
her top 10 rules for Success enjoy
rule number two Center yourself in
Stillness you want to learn how to
center yourself in Stillness
and that to me is easier said for many
than it is done but it's so worth doing
when you Center yourself in Stillness
and you fall into a place of gratitude a
place of I'm grateful for the
opportunity to be in demand instead of I
gotta do I gotta do I gotta do now I
know if you were a mover and Shaker and
a doer like I am Stillness feels like
it's like anti-productive but the
reality is when you get into movement
you want to make sure you're moving from
a place of core you're moving from a
place of groundedness and more
importantly and most importantly you're
moving from a place of gratitude because
gratitude gives you energy and when
you're serving everyone else it's energy
that we need so number one Center
yourself in Stillness and fall into a
space of gratitude about being in demand
about having a full schedule about being
someone that others can come to so
gratitude is the soil for All Good
Things rule number three give yourself
permission to be paid so many times we
want to be paid we want money we want
our bank account to just magically grow
without us doing the work necessary to
accept payment and if you're already
accepting payment do the work necessary
to accept a greater bigger Bolder
payment
I'll never forget when my fee was three
thousand dollars as a speaker I was like
oh my God this is everything and then it
went to 7 500 as a speaker I was so
scared like No One's Gonna hire me oh my
God it had nothing to do with the value
I brought on stage and then
I went to ten thousand dollars and I'm
like mortified I'm sweating everyone's
sweating and I remember I was at an
event with Les Brown and he went up and
he did it boom and I went up and I did
it boom boom and he looked at me and I
looked at him and we had a candid
conversation and he asked me my fee and
at the time I don't know what his fee
was maybe twenty thousand dollars or
something and he asked me my friend I
was like to ten thousand
and he looked at me and literally you
could see how the feed didn't match the
experience
now your feet doesn't match your worth
but I knew I should have been different
I knew that
and he looked at me and he said
he said if you charge five thousand
dollars and you play full out and do
what you just did and you go home with
five thousand dollars and the client
goes home Happy everyone's good right I
said yes he goes and if you charge
fifteen thousand dollars and you give
them what you just gave them and the
client goes so I'm happy and you go home
happy then all is good right I said yeah
he goes which experience do you want to
go home with
and I realized that it wasn't about the
business it was about my
self-development so I had to give myself
permission to be paid rule number four
get clear on who you are be super clear
about who you are and about what you
provide and how you serve people so in
order to do that you need to be super
clear write this down what's the problem
that you solve
or what's the desire that you help come
to fruition I know you've probably heard
me say that before but it's because the
truth doesn't change I'm not going to
give you 19 different answers to a
question when the one answer is the
answer it's the mecca answer right so
who are you and who are you to the world
a lot of times Diana We Touch no one
because we're trying to touch everyone
okay type your name in chat if that just
push the button for you like oh my God
that's me listen I'm not speaking from a
place of judgment or even as the coach
solely this was what I did remember my
company name is called motivating the
masses so I was trying to touch everyone
and I wasn't impacting or converting
anyone so be super clear on who you are
and what you provide as a service what
the pain is that you solve what the
desire is that you help bring to
fruition and how can you serve me right
remember you're not talking to everyone
you're talking to one person at a time
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five become assistant
you want to be consistent Diana you
talked about you post every other day
that sounds like it's consistent however
in the posting every other day are you
moving them through a journey are you
just providing content are you speaking
to something way out there are you
inviting them every third or every
second invitation or you're inviting
them to join are you inviting them in
such a way that you're inviting them to
get the solution to their problem by
choosing you or just inviting them to
subscribe or inviting them to follow you
I see so many entrepreneurs out there
doing it wrong because they're blending
social media with business building
media they're not the same they're both
done on social media but social media is
just hey let me let me hang out let me
Tick Tock let me share a little
something something with you business
building media is you have a strategy
I'm gonna I'm gonna serve serve serve
I'm gonna become the owner of this
content I'm gonna become considered the
expert in this area I'm going to invite
you to join me enjoy my tribe click here
come get this free you know assessment
that I have get this free newsletter app
if you want to grow in this area so it's
important to ask what I call a
benefit-based question if you want to
grow your business you want to be
consistent in your life I'm just making
this stuff up if you want to trim your
body and tone your muscles then like
join me here in this campus Because I
can help you get there versus just
follow me right so you want to be
consistent with your posting but you
want to post to a benefit-based problem
solution based and then you want to make
some invitations rule number six learn
how to sell Shirley asks how do I get
more leads for my business
super great question so the first thing
I'm going to say surely is be
responsible for the leads that you get
because leads are not sales leads are
people that are interested so I'm not
going to go into this particular answer
right now on this show but I am going to
say Shirley are you ready to sell do you
feel worthy of having someone choose you
are you making sure that you're ready to
ask for the business if not get ready to
ask for the business before you get the
leads because a lead will go cold if it
takes you too long to send them an
invitation to become your student your
client your partner in creation
so Shirley how do you get more leads in
your business so remember this people
either have a pain that they want you to
help them to eliminate or they have a
desire that they want you to help them
get
ask the question Shirley what pain do I
help to eliminate so I'm in the
transformational business and so I help
people eliminate the pain of limiting
belief systems I help people eliminate
the pain of negative self-talk I help
people eliminate the pain of holding
themselves back through what they say
and they believe now the desire I help
people get to as a transformational
coach is the desire to touch their next
best version of themselves the desire to
play their biggest game ever that their
desire to build a life that they've only
been dreaming about so I know the pain
that I help relieve and I know the
desire that I help fulfill so how do you
bring more leads into your business
understand that because people are not
interested surely and coming into your
business
people are interested in having their
desires met the desires of their heart
fulfilled they're interested in learning
the ABC or the one two three to get that
negative Nanny out of their lives that
negative idea thought or behavior as
well as to get that abundant possibility
into their lives so make it very clear
how you help them get there because
people are looking at you with a
w-i-i-f-m always what's in it for me the
clearer you can show people what's in it
for you for them to be with you the
faster they'll join your business and
become one of your email list
individuals now you haven't made them a
customer yet that's why I didn't say the
faster they'll become your customer so
the first thing they're going to do is
raise their hand that they want to learn
more from you how do you get them to do
that offer them something of value for
free so we call that a lead magnet if
you go to my website
motivatingthemasters.com right it gives
you an option are you a speaker or is it
personal development if you go down the
speaker path the first thing I'm gonna
say is hey do you want to go from being
a good speaker to an unforgettable
speaker that's my lead magnet for you
that's my offer join my free webinar
right so now I'm giving you something
that's of value for you in that area
that you have a pain or desire for free
to get your name into my database if you
go down my personal development path
it's the same thing it just focuses on
personal development so what's a juicy
sticky lead magnet that's for free that
gives them some of the answer that
they're looking for it could be the top
10 things that you can do let's say I'm
a makeup artist
what are the top 10 mistakes that most
amateurs make when they put their makeup
on I want to know what that is give me
your email and I'll send you those the
top 10 things so automatically offer
value in exchange for their information
now surely and others anyone once you
get that information you don't want to
just let them sit there what's the next
level that you want to offer them now I
don't say run from free to feet really
fast build relationships because when
you run from giving someone a free
something to charging them really fast
that's like saying hi my name is Lisa
want a kiss
no I Want to Hold Your Hand first I want
to know about you first so you want to
treat
people coming into your community the
same way don't try to convert so fast
build the relationship so when you make
the ask the ask is made on a more solid
ground so what does that look like
Shirley
it looks like offering them something
free that eliminates that pain or helps
them with that desire and then once they
get in maybe offer them an opportunity
to meet up with you hey I get together
every other week online 30 minutes and I
provide 30 minutes of content about this
thing rule number seven celebrate your
accomplishments you want to celebrate
and recognize what you've accomplished
already so build your business on cement
not sinking sand because you offer
something for free does not mean you
haven't made Major Impact in progress
now the other thing is that you want to
track here's the third area you want to
track the outcomes that are produced for
free
because free or feed does not change the
value let me just I should have started
with this
your fee and your value will not equal
so you can give me something for free
you can give it to me for ninety seven
dollars
my first program on my campus that you
can step into is 28 bucks
but the value of the program is intense
it's it's a three digit value at least
500 at least but it's 28 so that people
can easily say yes to themselves
so your feet and your worth do not equal
so often we have this idea of what
success looks like and what makes an
accomplishment valid I've learned that
almost always those are not our own
beliefs but the beliefs of others that
we've taken on
so I want you to take a minute and think
about what you've done in the past six
months
what have you done what have you
accomplished in the past year the past
five years listen I know that your to-do
list is really really long because
you're a gladiator and you're looking at
this video you're on this channel your
to-do list is long you want to produce
some things in the world but guess what
I will always challenge you that your
to-done list is much much longer you've
done so much in the last six months the
last year the last five years man now
what new accomplishments have you made
celebrate them be aware of them what old
accomplishments that are under
celebrated celebrate them you know why
because what's celebrated gets repeated
and celebration is the fuel to your
future like gratitude is the fuel to
your future be grateful and celebrate
what you've already done while you're
creating this for fee platform rule
number eight maintain healthy boundaries
maintain healthy boundaries
now I've managed this one for a long
time and when I say boundaries the first
thing you think is to tell people stop
to push people away and it's not that
it's recognizing that there's power in
yes
but there's power and no
and that a no can be a dignified no a no
can be a not now a no can be my plate is
currently full a no can mean that
doesn't work for me any kind of no as
long as it maintains your dignity and
maintains someone else's dignity is a
healthy no so when you set boundaries
all of a sudden you're opening up space
for yourself because when you say no to
something you're saying yes to something
else when you say no to going out in the
evening because you're tired you're
saying yes to getting more rest when you
say no to being able to handle someone
else's problem or their challenge you're
saying yes to spending more time in what
you need
saying no has always been something that
I've had to work on the recent years
I've gotten much much better at it
because I recognize that when I say no I
have more space for other things that I
needed to do recently I had a challenge
in my life where a family member got
really sick and I had to say no to a lot
I mean a lot almost everything that
wasn't focusing on my very dear dear
family member getting better
and I thought in my head everything was
going to fall apart because I said no to
so many things what happened was the
people around me Rose up to the occasion
they managed exactly what needed to be
managed and I had the freedom of Mind
space
to just be pray have faith and sit at
the hospital bedside of my family
and so maintaining healthy boundaries
can really be the first step of you
recognizing one other people want to
rise up to the occasion for you and two
there's healing and having the
spaciousness to look at your own life
to press reset
to reflect rule number nine make real
connections you want to get from behind
the screen and make real connections so
Diana I'm not sure how you're doing your
post but sometimes you can post every
day
you can post twice a day and still have
no connection so you want to look at the
people who are creating great connection
on camera what are some of the key
things they're doing because trust me
it's not just an experience there's some
techniques and if you're on my campus
you know there's some clear techniques
you want to do the audience connection
formula and the audience connection
formula you want to do that as much as
possible that's the me we you so you
want to start with there was a time when
I and go back to a time when you had a
struggle and then the second one is the
we we have a tendency to and then share
something that we as Humanity have a
tendency to do then the third part is
have you ever asked a question that
allows the audience to go yeah that's so
me when you do a benefit-based question
there was a time when I didn't think
that I could stand in front of the
camera and bring value we all have a
tendency to minimize our greatness and
to minimize our skill set based on who
we were in the past has there ever been
a time when you knew that you wanted to
do something but you immediately thought
you were weren't qualified to do it I
just did it to you me we you might want
to press rewind to see that again as
smooth as butter and what happens when
you do the me Wii U audience connection
formula is that people start seeing
themselves in you and it becomes a tribe
experience versus you just dictating to
them so you want to make sure that you
up level your connections and Rule
Number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is build your
credibility you want to get people's
connection to you by building your
credibility in that area so serve them
think about the guy at the mall in the
food court that gives free samples of
the orange chicken you know like if you
ever go to the mall there's that one
place that's given free samples have you
ever noticed that their line is the
longest for customers it's like the best
example ever so when the malls are fully
back open again and everything's back up
forward to its new Norm go and check and
if in this new climate we can do that
still you'll notice that there's this
person giving samples you know why
because they're so confident that you're
gonna like that orange chicken that
you're gonna get in line and innately I
always wonder why aren't they giving
away a free little bit of corn dog why
aren't they giving away a free little
French fry why aren't they giving away
free small slices of pizza are they all
not looking at this dude having the
longest line in the food court at the
mall
sample let people be bold
and be be bold and audacious about your
content give people value for free and
then invite them my last last piece is
make an invitation
if this was a value for you I'd like to
invite you
step number five you want to take the
techniques the previous four techniques
that I've given you and if you're in any
one of my courses it's actually 17
techniques and you want to make it sound
like a symphony and and the reason why
this is a step is because most people
look at techniques and look at things
they do very fragmented well I'm gonna
say and I like to call it two things one
make it sound like a symphony meaning
you want your message to blend together
think of it as if you were writing a
song because a message should be
rhythmic it should be like a song it
should have this Cadence to it it should
have this alliteration to it it should
have this flow to it it has this opening
it has this middle this Arc and it has
this ending and it all comes together
right that's the symphony that's the
sound that's the band
the other way you can look at it is you
want to take your individual ingredients
and then you want to layer them together
like lasagna
and you want to put them on lasagna is
actually not one of the easiest dishes
to make because it's about individual
Mastery of the particular taste and the
particular seasonings and then it's also
about layering it in such a way that it
meshes together and comes out in one
form that's how a great message is you
take the techniques audience connection
you take the techniques ending with a
fire not a fizzle you take the
techniques understanding what's in it
for your audience you take the
techniques verbal highlights and you do
all these techniques and then you go how
do I layer them content and story and
opening and clothes yeah again I say
this ain't Elementary this is MBA right
so it takes a minute but if you've
implemented the first four steps then
you have delicious content
you understand what a soul-stirring
story looks like because I taught you
the valley you understand the crescendo
in a close now it's time for you as the
conductor or like my son jaylani as the
head chef
as he is a a chef of all times now you
want to put the dish together or as the
conductor you want to create a beautiful
Symphony of words
yeah I know when you think of it that
way it's like well Lisa it's just a
message no it's not it's life for
someone who's listening it's life for
someone who needs your words so take the
time and create a symphony of oration
create a symphony of possibility create
a symphony of energy because when you
speak and you speak possibility you
speak education you speak motivation
you're speaking life step three is about
designing your powerful clothes so most
people end with a fizzle
and I'm gonna say the one of the major
foundations to a powerful message is to
end with fire
like fire
so in with fire not a fizzle speakers
often Overlook and dismiss the clothes
because they're so committed to the
content and they think oh it's the end
no like think about it when you're at a
concert when you're at a concert and
like you're with like a mega artist like
a mega artist like if it were Prince or
Tina Turner or Janet Jackson or Beyonce
or Mary J Blige or if you're with Kenny
G or you're like you're just you have a
a a concert a major concert they don't
end with the fizzle they don't end with
the the song that no one knew that
didn't go gold or didn't hit a major
status or that you you can't sing along
with they crescendo
and they may go down and give you some
of the you know ones that are more
mediocre in the middle but at the end
they come out and do the Encore even and
The Encore is always something that gets
everyone to sing along it's an encore
that just it's fire
that's exactly how your message needs to
be so let me let you in on the secret
sauce like a lot of things that I love
to do now is really taking you behind
the black curtain on powerful speeches
behind the black curtain on becoming
Unforgettable when you open your mouth
or when you present in front of people
your clothes here here it is you ready
for it you ready for it
your clothes is so important
it's the audience's last impression of
you and most people go height height
height
and down and bye
I've I've witnessed so many times great
speeches
great speeches
speeches that kept me engaged
and kept me excited
until the end
every time this happens I'm screaming
inside my head no
no a fizzle you need to have content and
you need to have stories now the number
of stories that you offer in your
message has a lot to do with how much
time you have because you always want to
give your audience of one or of many
online virtual or live you want to give
them enough content to walk away with
value however it's super important that
you give them enough story to walk away
with a connection so what normally
happens
some of the best speakers that are out
there today best presenters
they are only doing one or the other
they fall flat in one of those areas
they're either all story and you don't
have enough content to write down or
they're all content that's pretty much
the majority of people they're all
content and there's very few
opportunities to make a connection so
why do you deliver content you deliver
content because it's the intellectual
learning that you're going to teach your
audience right whether it's new Concepts
it's the theory that provides your
audience with the insight to move
forward content is the steps that the
how to content is where they choose to
follow you as an expert as a coach as a
leader because you have Insight on
neuro-linguistic programming behavior
management media marketing you you got
that content on personal perseverance
and transformation you are the content
provider for that particular body of
work meaning your intellectual property
will help move them forward in their
life in that area super super important
now that I want you to put that by
itself that's important the mistake most
speakers make most presenters make is
that they give you all of that well I
walk away with value
but you miss a huge part of me
now where is that that's from the story
so the story is that experience that you
share that grounds the content and makes
it real now you don't have to
necessarily point to the content you're
just sharing a story about a time in
your life and that story just gives
context it gives 3D it gives texture
what I like to call it to what you're
talking about to the content it brings
the content to life in a moment let me
give an example
well the story is what allows the
audience to see themselves in you
the story is what creates the the the
vibration the energy exchange remember
content doesn't create an energy
exchange content creates an intellectual
exchange you want an energy exchange why
content will have people respect you
stories will have people become loyal to
you this is about step four this one is
huge for connecting with your audience
and keeping them interested and engaged
now so many times I see speakers as
presenters speaking and they're not
checking in with their audience to even
see if they're listening anymore and as
a result people are on their phones or
they're doing whatever they're
multitasking you want to keep your
audience absolutely engaged
so let me give you some techniques you
want to identify your audience's drivers
you want to know these things before you
even open your mouth like you want to
know what makes your audience tick what
gets them excited what gets them into
action what's super important to them
what's the
w-i-i-f-m what's in it for me but in
this case what's in it for them what
drives them what motivates them this
step is beyond customizing your speech
which is what I mentioned in a previous
show this is really understanding the
psychographic of your audience whether
you're on social media that's an
audience whether you're teaching a class
that's an audience whether you're
talking to one individual that's an
audience so you have to ask yourself
what's the red button for this
particular group of individuals when I
speak to mothers I recognize that a
mother's job is to make her children
feel safe her mother's job is to make
them feel loved a mother also feels
overwhelmed she's also the multitasker
of all times she also needs rest and she
wants to be acknowledged many times
she's under acknowledged I know that I
know that before I start talking to the
moms or even when I'm talking to an
audience and I say if you are a mother
then and I go I begin to go into the
things that I know is important to a
mother if I'm speaking to a group of
speakers or entrepreneurs then I know
it's about several things it's about
impact you want your voice to be heard
you also want to know that your voice is
powerful you want to know that your
message is being received you also want
to monetize your message so it's not
just about speaking it's also about the
business if I'm speaking to teens during
our motivating the Teen Spirit events
then as a teen I go okay so teens are
not making a lot of decisions in their
lives for themselves decisions are being
made around they want to own their voice
they want to hear their own voice
they're tired of rules so in the
motivating the Teen Spirit when I'm
talking to teens I say here are no rules
they go what
in this space we just make agreements
together man they perk up as soon as I
do that because they're not used to that
so to that point you want to make sure
that you understand what the needs and
the desires and what motivates the
audience that you're speaking to before
you even open your mouth you don't want
to just speak to what's important to you
you want to speak to what's important to
them and what are those hot buttons what
are those red buttons that will make
them go look
let me listen a Little Closer
this part of the process may sound like
a lot of work but it's worth it because
it can turn a speech a message into an
experience customize your content for
each event I cannot tell you how many
times I see speakers and orators and
teachers and whoever and they have a
really great message but with each new
audience they go to 90 of the message is
the same I gotta be honest with you some
of the people that I know in the
industry some of my friends they do it
and I love them and I love their heart
but I truly believe that the audience is
paying for the lack of energy let me
just say lazy
the audience is paying because you're
being lazy
customize
your message for your audience who are
they how are they different and even if
it's the same demographic so they're
still women and they're still
entrepreneurs but are we in a different
time I dare not deliver the exact same
message this year to the same
demographic that I delivered in 2019.
why too much has happened
she he they are in a totally new place
so you want to make sure that your
message addresses your audience now let
me just tell you something I saw a very
powerful speaker I will not mention his
name
I saw a very powerful speaker be so sure
that he can move the audience that when
he was speaking to his audience he
actually went in a direction that this
audience wasn't interested in
but it's where his speech was and it was
a great speech great speech
for another audience
and he was on autopilot I so I want you
to think about it this way
you don't talk to everyone in your life
the same way you know if you were
talking to a three-year-old you have a
three-year-old's conversation if you
were talking to a 15 year old
you have a 15 year old's conversation to
relate to them and if you were talking
to a 55 year old
or let's just look at me because that's
where I happen to be right now in my
life you would speak to me differently
and so you don't speak to your partner
the way you speak to your boss the way
you speak to your children the way you
speak to your friend you talk to them in
a way that fits the relationship that
you're in with them your audience is the
exact same way taking the time to
customize your message you can be
talking about the same content same
content same technique I teach about
speaking all the time but I'm always
saying am I talking to a corporate
employee am I talking to a corporate
exec am I talking to an entrepreneur am
I speaking to a teenager same content
but I apply the message so that it fits
the audience this allows the audience to
feel as if you've customized something
for them and they have a more intimate
connection to you you may ask how do you
customize
how do you customize Lisa a message for
your audience how do you know what the
audience needs that's what I would be
asking me right now how do I know what
the audience needs ask questions
write this down
your listeners or your customers are the
experts
say that my customers are the experts my
students are the experts the next line I
am the service provider
oh when I got that years ago that my
customers my audience my students you
you're the expert
you're the expert of your journey
because you know what you need more than
I do you're the expert on what you need
I'm the service provider so the best
thing you can do is ask questions what
matters to you most these days what
problem are you working to solve what's
keeping you up at night what would what
era would you love to grow in what's
your pain Point what are the 10 things
that you're tolerating right now they're
not screaming loud enough to make you
change them but they're screaming loud
enough to annoy you
I ask those questions collect the data
put it in your back pocket and as you're
creating content and as you're creating
programs create programs and content
that speaks to what your audience has
already shared with you your belief
systems were handed to you by your
parents and by your grandparents and
they were pretty much embedded by the
time you were 10 years old so there's
some beliefs that you didn't even have a
chance to develop for your own you just
are living them out you inherited them
you inherit the beliefs and didn't
unconsciously inherited them and so the
good news is you get to choose to the
belief systems you like and then you get
to divorce I'm gonna say divorce because
that's a strong word we all know what
separation looks like when you say
divorce you get to divorce from a belief
system that doesn't serve you any longer
a belief system that says money is the
root of all evil maybe or a belief
system that says only rich people have
money or all rich people are are are
Crooks or I use that my belief system
used to be that wealthy people aren't
spiritual that if I'm wealthy I can't be
a spiritual person you have to to pick
God or money one or the other that's
what pick my faith or my finances I
can't have both that's a belief system
and and I invite you to divorce it
because it's not the case I have both
and I live in both quite well I use my
money for good in the world and the more
good the more money you have the more
good you'll do if you're a good person
so money makes you more of who you are
so you will only be more of who you are
with money when we talk about setting
healthy boundaries again and I know it
sounds as if I keep going back to the
same thing but setting healthy
boundaries is not about you keeping
other people out
if someone crosses the your Line in the
Sand it's because you never made your
line deep enough
no one can ever go further with you than
you've given them permission to go so as
hard and as difficult as it is to hear
because this was hard for me to hear
when I had to admit it to myself that
the way people treated me was based on
how I trained them to treat me
so I have to say it to you you've
trained people to treat you the way
they're treating you so if people are
crossing your boundaries because they
didn't know it was there if people call
you at odd hours a night it's because
you keep answering if people ask you to
do beyond what you're able to do it's
because you keep saying yes if people
don't ever think you need rest it's
because you act like you don't need rest
I know this is not probably what you
want to hear but I signed up and you
signed up in this relationship to give
you what you need to hear not
necessarily what's always easy to hear
and I'm only telling you what I needed
to hear myself I'm only telling you the
lesson that I had to learn that we train
people how to treat us acknowledge your
community see when you celebrate the
people around you that bring you Joy or
that teach you some of the hardest
lessons that you need to learn the iron
that sharpens the iron the celebrators
that celebrate you those who hold the
space for you and with you pray for you
honor you when you celebrate and lift
them up the whole Tide Rises so I want
you to find six people in your community
not out of obligation but truly out of
choice
they can be in your circle in your
family in your business Circle and I
want you to acknowledge them for the
contribution that they bring to your
life what I love about acknowledgment is
that when you acknowledge other people
that it actually makes you happier it's
just this amazing gift of giving and
what I love is that most people would
rather get an acknowledgment from you
than a physical gift that means they
don't necessarily need the perfume they
don't need the sweater they don't need
the new iPhone whatever they want you to
look at them in their eyes and say you
bring value you bring value to my life
I honor you I celebrate you I appreciate
you take time to have a personal moment
with them where you're just seeing them
the number one reason why people feel
sad and disconnected is because they say
they don't feel seen
so in this acknowledgment I want you to
look into their eyes and acknowledge
them for who they are and how they make
your life better when you raise the
community around you the entire Tide
Rises the energy Rises the joy Rises the
expectation Rises and guess what if you
make this a part of your weekly habits
with them I didn't say daily I didn't
say monthly either and I definitely
didn't say annually but if you make this
a part of your weekly find one thing to
acknowledge at least six people in your
community for each week one you'll feel
like you'll feel much more excited but
all of a sudden there's a vibration that
happens because you've created it
there's this energy of let's go do this
because what gets celebrated gets
repeated you want someone to repeatedly
do something wonderful and amazing in
your life you repeatedly acknowledge
them from a genuine place man it's so
powerful when you truly marry yourself
to the acknowledgment process to the
practice of acknowledgment when you get
into the practice of acknowledgment all
of a sudden people will mirror back to
you you don't acknowledge to get it back
you acknowledge because you want people
to be seen but there's just this this
dance that begins to occur that's
absolutely delicious our try says I'll
make a feeble attempt I will it's
absolute non-negotiable no matter what
there's a certain energy that goes forth
when you say I'll try and there's a
different energy that goes forth when
you say I will when you make the
Declaration of I will that says Mountain
if you were there you must move I'll try
says I hope I got enough energy to make
it up or around the mountain and if not
I'ma sit at the bottom of the hill when
you fail to make a plan okay hold on
this might hit you between the eyes you
know I love you but when you fail to
make a clear concrete plan that has
goals and Milestones meaning they're
smaller goals that you can hit to get to
the bigger goal and has a buy win date
not in February not in August but August
15th
by 5 PM Eastern Standard Time yeah when
I set a goal I even want to know the
time zone I'm gonna have it done by
Clarity when you fail to make a plan
with clear distinction when you fail to
make a clear plan you have clearly
planned to fail I'll say it again when
you fail to make a clear plan then
you've clearly plan to fail I know that
hits you hard I've done it many times I
have clearly planned to fail many times
because I had an idea and it was just in
my unconscious I didn't know now I want
to bring to you what I know to you so
you know it I want you to make a clear
plan when you create a clear plan then
you're clearly planning to succeed every
relationship is a relay it's like my
dad's played tennis for over 40 years
and and I've attempted to play with them
at times and what I realize is that
relationships are like a tennis match I
hit the ball to you you hit the ball
back
and a relationship where you think it's
only about one person that's not tennis
that's racquetball
right but a relationship is a tennis
match and so if a relationship is
working it's because of the way we both
are engaging if it's truly working and
if it's not working it's the way we both
are engaging and so there could be
passive engagement
and there could be active engagement so
when you're not speaking up for what you
want when you're holding and you're
living with a bunch of withholds that's
engagement that's just the way you're
engaging so so every relationship has
two parts whether your part is active or
your part is passive every relationship
has engagement a level of Engagement and
that engagement is on different levels
if you find that the relationships
around you have toxic outcomes then I
want you to look at where's the
breakdown is the breakdown in
communication is the breakdown in how
you communicate the words you're using
is a breakdown in who you choose to be
around as the breakdown in the
engagement of what you're talking about
what I've learned is that if you're not
talking about things that are high
enough and big enough things that are
inspiring enough you will slip into the
smallness every single time if you don't
choose an intentionally High evolving
encouraging conversation you will slip
into the tracks you will slip into those
crevices of smallness and Petty and
until you get people trained that you're
going to live up here without telling
them I need you to know it's not an
announcement it's a way of being and so
what do you choose to participate in
it's a stepping over your desire to hear
smallness
gossip
negative feedback it's when someone is
engaging in negative feedback about
someone else the fact that you didn't
add anything to the conversation doesn't
let you off the hook did you stop the
conversation
did you say hold on I don't want to
engage in speaking negatively of them at
all why don't you have a conversation
with them it's course correcting
behaviors in your space at the risk at
the risk of losing the relationship but
what you basically do is is you say
here's where I play
here is where I live I'm not visiting
this High Road of Integrity I'm not
visiting this High Road of conscious
thinking and awareness and respect and
humility and and honoring the dignity
and people I don't visit this place I
live here
I don't visit this place
I live here and in a loving way anyone
that's engaging with you has two choices
they either engage with you here or they
choose to engage with someone else
now if you find that you're going down
to be in the relationship or you're
going down and you're taking and you're
the person taking the relationship down
because you're in a moment of anger are
you in a moment of resentment are you in
a moment of hurt then you're not living
in your highest Integrity you just visit
every now and again when you come to
this channel
uh oh I see my my
Shantae coming out right now Shantae is
my middle name is what I do when I start
getting real edgy because I really want
you to get it
so you need to make a decision on where
you choose to reside
and then you don't leave your conscious
neighborhood
to go visit other people's neighborhood
if it's not as high as yours
people will rise to the occasion or
they'll choose not to rise and they'll
pick other people to be with and hang
with and I know that sounds easier said
than done because some of the people who
are playing at a lower level might be in
family it might be and that's fine too
you can love people it doesn't mean you
have to spend tons and tons and tons of
time if that time costs you something
spend as much time as you can spend as
much time as serves you spend as much
time as they will allow you to spend but
never leave this place
even if being with them causes you to to
allow them to be where they are you
don't have to engage in that so the
bottom line and supporting you to either
recognize are you the toxic element are
you surrounding yourself in toxic
element is to make a commitment where
you live
where am I living and first own where
you're currently living because if you
own it you might go you know what I do
slip into that small place okay own it
that's conscious awareness that's
powerful own it and then go where do I
want to be and then what's the distance
between here and there and what do I
have to do to get there or I have to say
no to we'll have to participate in we'll
have to ask forgiveness for we'll have
to clean up what relationships require
cleaning up and then what declarations
must I make and what decisions must I
live in don't make a decision living
your decision did you consciously sit
down and say I want to manifest
inspiring millions of people making
millions of dollars was it was it a
conscious thing were there moments where
you sat there when you weren't living in
that reality where you said you know
what I'm going to decide I'm going to
figure it out I might not know how I not
know where or what but I'm going to
commit to it and make it a reality I
mean talk to me at the core of your
experience right so I love how you say
made millions of dollars I said I want
to inspire people and I want to be able
to pay my bills that was initially I
wanna I wanna have a I want to run out a
month
before I run out of money
I want to have enough that like you
can't think about having abundance until
you you literally give yourself
permission to have enough your past
scarcity yeah like so I want to have
enough to dream and so my first I I have
I think I have a Ministry mindset my
first I just want to help people I want
to help people who and I want to I want
to be rewarded for my efforts right and
then once I got past that I said okay
I want more
I want to generate Millions I want to
serve Millions Inspire millions and
generate Millions I I think I deserve
all of that but that have to do with my
self-worth right I had to feel worthy to
touch Millions
and I have to feel worthy to touch
Millions I have to feel worthy of both
and so that was personal development
which is why I live and I stay in
personal development I teach personal
development I teach wealth development I
teach Business Development and I teach
personal development because you have to
have both I'm only telling you the
lesson that I had to learn that we train
people how to treat us in 2007 when I
was on the Oprah show it was the thing
that came up and out of me and she was
like yes it was that thing that said we
train people how to treat us like
they're looking at how we're what we're
saying yes to and what we're co-signing
on and if we're the yes woman or the Yes
Man all the time then one our yes isn't
as valuable because everyone
automatically expects it because we give
it away all the time and two they're
gonna keep asking because they know
we're gonna get that they're gonna get
yes and if you're a producer and
deliverer you're the one I'm gonna come
to all the time because your producer
and deliverer you're gonna get the job
done even to the detriment of your own
Joy even to the detriment of your own
happiness but again
you train people how to treat you but
the good news about training someone
is that they can be retrained practice
active yes I'm gonna say it again
underline Circle active practice active
self-care that's where you identified
what rejuvenates you and made plans to
make time for self-care during the busy
season so you made a list of what you
know rejuvenates your soul your mind
your body your spirit from walking on
the beach to reading a book to taking
down time free things and Retreats or a
spa whatever it is that rejuvenates your
soul to make a list of it and then to
make plans active self-care to do those
things during your busy season to the
conversation about money and wealth
um it it's one being willing to release
a familiar now for an unfamiliar future
now that's that's easier said than done
and it's bigger than it sounds
are you willing to have your future look
unfamiliar and in some cases look around
and you don't recognize anything
are you willing are you so tied to the
comfort of what you know even in its
discomfort so I was willing to reinvent
myself a thousand times are you willing
to reinvent yourself are you willing to
introduce yourself to the new version of
you yes are you willing to go places you
wouldn't go and do things that you
traditionally wouldn't do see I wasn't
traditionally in meditation or in
visualization or hanging around older
white men or like I had a thousand
things that I didn't do traditionally
see it's very difficult to speak
phenomenally and to not be good come on
y'all from y'all say not be great but to
be what
[Applause]
unfreaking forgettable
it's difficult to be Unforgettable while
you're still trying to look good
you can't do two things that's chasing
two rabbits see Unforgettable has
everything to do with serving at a level
so high so big so massive that people
feel like they have to change their
lives because they crossed your path
yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes
see see when you're willing
to use your voice first you have to
recognize that you have one
you got to recognize that that no matter
your past you were given a voice and the
your voice was given not to keep to
yourself your voice is not a secret
says the secret teacher
and you have to be willing to use every
experience that's ever happened in your
life not as a fortress holding you from
using your voice but as the fuel on why
you will use your voice
you got to be willing to not stand in
your story but stand on your story
yes yes it's not in spite of your past
that you get to be amazing that you get
to be a change agent that you get to
transform lives it's because of your
past that you're perfect for such a job
when you own it like that see there's no
question in my certainty about my life
can you walk with that level of
certainty so that when the wind comes
and then when the wind blows and it will
come and it will blow and it will be a
storm and it will be a tornado and it
will look like divorce and it will look
like bankruptcy and it will look like an
illness and it will look like a loss
when it comes it will rock you it will
rock you it will rock you but it won't
move you the Oprah team had heard some
of my backstory
and they said can we send a camera crew
much like this wonderful camera crew yes
not nearly as good looking
um and can we send a camera crew to
capture your story
and so I I share my story and I mean I
dumped
and dumped
and I shared the ugly
and right after the interview I
regretted it
because I I didn't think I could be the
secret teacher
the expert and have that kind of ugly
out there in the world I didn't know I
didn't know that the world would love me
for what I've come through I thought
that they would they would consider me
an imposter in the secret
and so I share all this junk
two weeks later I'm on my way to Oprah
to do the actual recording and I know
what I record I know the video
so the night before I'm packing and I'm
crying oh my God
that it's over tomorrow it's all over
we're gonna embarrass myself it's the
fastest career up and down is what
anyone's ever seen Lisa Nichols will be
the secret yes right so
um
so I I'm just sad I'm scared and I and I
call a friend of mine at 4 15 in the
morning because I stayed up all night of
course yeah how are you gonna sleep
before that you're right right and I
said oh my God I know there you go to my
junk in the video and I'm it's over and
he said can I pray for you Lisa and I
was like sure
my friend says God thank you for using
your imperfect child to help your
imperfect children
I went over the next day
and as the chatter kept going in my head
leading up to the moment when they play
this video
I'm like it's okay
I'm enough
I'm enough with all my mess I'm enough
I'm enough and the chatter kept no
they're gonna find out they're gonna
find out your son's father is in jail
they're gonna find out that they're
gonna find out and I thought no they're
not gonna find out because I'ma tell
them
because there's power and transparency
there's power and authenticity
power and truth that I'm gonna speak
life into someone else because they're
gonna see who I am because of that in
spite of that with that and so then the
after show came so after the regular
Oprah show the after show and man I
cracked open on the after show and
within 72 hours talk about the power of
transparency and authenticity within 72
hours I received
8782 emails and my email wasn't even
Lisa Nichols it wasn't even easy to find
and my website wasn't Lisa Nichols Yeah
they people searching for me whatever it
took because of the truth and so I have
the Imposter syndrome then I've had it
since then people told me oh my God
you're the answer and I'm searching for
my own answers when we talk about living
our Quest
um I think that living my quest really
if I look at on a daily basis it's
finding my own voice
it's finding your voice it's finding the
song that only you can sing
off-key or not
it's finding your rhythm
it's discovering what it feels like to
walk in your shoes today it won't look
like it looked 10 years ago live in your
quest is what can I do with my life so
that my life becomes infectious to
someone else
living my quest looks like how do I make
my fingerprint
matters so big that it lives beyond my
transition day
living your quest is how can I forgive
the perceivingly unforgivable so I can
love the absolute lovable
living your quest is how do I give
myself a thousand Second Chances and
every time I get to 9.99 press reset
yeah yeah
living my quest is is not some ambiguous
Untouchable experience
living my quest means going back and
healing the little girl in me
so that the woman can be free
it's going back and embracing the little
boy in you so that the man can show up
and give himself permission to cry when
necessary living your quest is not
something that you can't touch it's not
something that requires a stage or
lights or cameras living your quest is
being complete and content with who you
are in the dark of the night so who you
are in the middle of the day is all
right
living your quest is as simple as it is
complex
living your quest is about giving
yourself permission say permission
on a daily basis to become the next best
version of yourself
living your quest is not holding
yourself Hostage to Old decisions not
holding yourself Hostage to shame blame
guilt regret and anger living your quest
is about recognizing that every day I
can be reborn to my possibility
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
about the law of attraction Secrets
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there then I'm gonna
feel so great now that well then they're
back to the program waiting for it to
happen for them to feel the emotion
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's there's no